and I realized not so long ago hi Brian
thanks to your questions I'm Andy Wales
I work for the brewer FCB Miller and the
most interesting idea I've heard today
is about the water food energy Nexus and
how for example throwing the food we
need growing the clothes that we wear
creating the energy that we use every
day takes a huge amount of water in fact
it takes for example 6,000 liters of
water to grow the cotton to make a pair
of jeans and so we had a big session
this morning launching a new book the
water security which talked about some
of the ways the companies and NGOs and
UN organizations are trying to link
together food water and energy so we can
be more sustainable in all of them so
that everyone on the planet can live to
a decent quality of life within the
ecosystem that we have and you can
actually find out more if you buy the
book or see the book water security it's
online on the Left website soon and also
if you go to the Young Global Leaders
campaign ygl water.org which looks at
how you can take action and to actually
reduce your own water use okay